[Musica]
la prima volta che sono scoppiata a
piangere in un contesto professionale ed
è in seconda elementare
i miei genitori avevano smesso di
parlarsi avevano iniziato a dividere
bene abitudini e a separare la mia
famiglia per sempre
ricordo che la mia maestra di matematica
Mi asciugo le lacrime
la prima volta che ho lasciato una
stanza professionale sbattendo la porta
e alle medie
stavamo guardando un filmato un po'
violento sulla seconda guerra mondiale
pochi giorni prima una delle mie
migliori amiche
era stata investita muovendo sul colpo
mentre attraversava la strada
e la mia professoressa di Storia mi
trovo a rannicchiata in bagno
adolescenza
per me era chiaro quanto l'amore potesse
fare male e quando la vita potesse
finire all'improvviso
e quindi iniziai per reazione a
proteggermi dalle mie stesse emozioni
chiudendomi me stessa
non è un robot però e quindi molto
presto inizia a soffrire di fortissimi
mal di testa ed insonnia così mi rivolsi
al medico di famiglia che in un paese di
8.000 abitanti conosceva il contesto da
cui provenivo e che mi suggerì di
rivolgermi una psicologa
per la prima volta a 15 anni
iniziai a contare la mia storia ad alta
voce quello che era stato il mio grande
dolore e piano piano a distendere quella
tensione Peccato non fosse finita lì
troppo facile se no
quando avevo 18 anni mia madre ha deciso
di seguire il compagno a 300 km di
distanza
avvenendo inavvertitamente quella che è
la paura più grande per la figlia ai
genitori separati cioè l'essere
abbandonata
le emozioni si facevano veramente tanto
importanti
Ma io ero più forte ero molto
determinata e una ragazza molto tosta mi
ero allenata in una palestra di judo per
16 anni non so se siete mai stati in un
Dojo in una di quelle palestre
giapponesi in cui ci sono questi
materassini tatami dove la prima cosa la
cosa principale che si fa
è il cadere cadere per rialzarsi
cadere per rialzarsi di imparare
qualcosa di nuovo ad ogni caduta Io ho
molto allenata vincevo Tra l'altro
sempre con i miei compagni maschi
questi questo questa capacità di
imparare di allenarmi di essere
determinata e tenace di indirizzare le
mie energie verso qualcosa di molto
chiaro
Mi ha aiutato a indirizzare il mio
futuro verso l'unica
soluzione che vedevo per me cioè
l'università
quindi testa bassa sugli Alpha Test sono
stata ammessa nell'università migliore
d'Italia dove studiare economia e dove
ho iniziato a frequentare nuovi compagni
di università di classe nuove amicizie
mi sono spostata a quel punto a Milano
in una residenza dovevamo più di 250
E questi più di 250 nuovi coinquilini
erano per me una nuova fonte di esempio
erano per me qualcuno da cui poteva
prendere con cui potevo condividere una
grandissima nuova un grandissimo nuovo
inizio
Peccato che quella mia capacità di
tenere le emozioni sotto controllo ma
avesse rigidità tantissimo e quindi
quando arrivava la sessione di esami
io sfogavo tutta la mia ansia su questi
miei amici su questi miei compagni di
residenza che giustamente mi evitavano e
avevo molti comportamenti rigidi perché
per me quella rigidità era stata era
stata la soluzione la sopravvivenza la
sopravvivenza emotiva a tutta quella
sofferenza che avevo imparato a gestire
e quindi ero convinta di non poter
cambiare Ero convinta di Dover
di dover proteggere quei miei
comportamenti per sopravvivere
e la colpa agli altri cioè sono gli
altri che non capiscono quanto ha
sofferto sono gli altri che mi creano
una barriera davanti quindi giustamente
con questa capacità di andare avanti
dritta per la mia strada ho iniziato poi
a lavorare in un'azienda molto grande
italiana
dove avevo avuto l'occasione di lavorare
con manager e dall'esperienza
internazionale che mi hanno fatto
crescere tantissimo da un punto di vista
analitico strategico
nonostante questo questa grande nuova
opportunità di nuovo mi trovavo in
situazioni in cui avevo dei
comportamenti di cui non vado tanto
fiera
per esempio mi succedeva che mi
arrabbiassi quando i miei colleghi non
ascoltavano quello che avevo da dire
anche se a volte quello che avevo da
dire non è molto utile a loro che
avevano molta più esperienza di me
oppure quando veniva promosso qualcuno
che non stimavo vivevo un senso di forza
ingiustizia
Oppure ancora
mi vergognavo profondamente degli errori
che facevo piccoli e grandi anche se gli
altri non se ne accorgevano e credo che
alcuni di questi comportamenti li
abbiate vissuti anche voi magari più
all'inizio della vostra esperienza
lavorativa che non oggi
Ma io all'epoca ancora davo la colpa
agli altri cioè io ero giusta così era
il contesto che non mi aiutava a
sprigionare la mia il mio potenziale la
mia energia e quindi decise di cambiare
nuovamente lavoro quindi contesto
iniziai così a lavorare in un negozio di
una multinazionale del della tecnologia
dove ogni giorno aveva contatto con
centinaia se non migliaia di persone e
dove quella rigidità diventava veramente
difficile da mantenere
Oltretutto il ruolo dei miei colleghi
dei miei responsabili e a quello di
insegnarmi la leadership cioè insegnarmi
a guidare il team verso una direzione
unica da arrivare a un obiettivo comune
e fortunatamente in quel nuovo contesto
mi venne dato un nuovo strumento che
possiamo chiamare zoom out Cioè la
capacità
allenata di fermarmi a pensare quando
succedeva qualcosa che attivava questo
genere di emozioni per quale motivo mi
sentissi in un certo modo E per quale
motivo gli altri reagissero in un certo
modo ai miei atteggiamenti
questa capacità dello zoom out è
qualcosa che avviene in un in un Doge in
una palestra cioè io mi alleno tuttora a
fare meglio a capire perché gli altri
agiscono e Agiscono nei miei confronti
in determinati modi e oggi mi succede
che non mi arrabbio più quando gli altri
non mi ascoltano ma mi chiedo se sto
dicendo qualcosa di valore e se la sto
dicendo nel modo corretto e se l'altra
persona in quel momento può ascoltare le
mie parole
oppure non mi vergogno più se faccio
degli errori mi chiedo se ho gli
strumenti per fare gli errori per fare
le cose bene
abbracciando di fatto quell'essere umano
che sono Oppure se qualcuno viene
promosso anche se non ha la mia stima
perché questo succede chiaramente ancora
oggi Mi chiedo cosa quella persona ha
capito più di me cosa posso imparare io
da lei
E ho deciso che quello che voglio fare
della mia vita oggi è aiutare il più
grande numero di persone possibili ad
avvicinarsi a questa palestra questo
zoom out
Voglio aiutare specialmente le
organizzazioni a supportare le loro
persone ad hackerare le loro
potenzialità quindi a rompere quegli
automatismi che a me hanno fatto tanto
male e che anche se non fanno male
bloccano la nostra potenzialità
Io credo che oggi in Italia ci sia un
grosso problema di produttività
il mercato del lavoro non riesce a
crescere il mercato in generale non
riesce a crescere e spesso Questo
succede perché
noi stessi ognuno individualmente Ci
chiudiamo dentro le nostre emozioni non
riusciamo a esprimere noi stessi Non
riusciamo a confrontarci con gli altri
in un modo adeguato
io ho imparato che la vita è un percorso
collettivo che Noi cresciamo ed
impariamo con gli altri e grazie agli
altri e sono molto orgogliosa oggi di
dire che al centro della metodologia che
abbiamo disegnato cioè proprio lo
scambio umano perché noi possiamo
imparare a crescere imparare a capire
come funzioniamo solo
confrontandoci con gli altri solo
potendo parlare con persone che vivono
le nostre azioni e le nostre azioni e
che ci dicono che cosa trasmettiamo loro
e credo che oggi più che mai abbiamo
tutti il dovere di hackerare Il nostro è
la nostra capacità di fare zoom
Grazie
[Applauso]